we're now continuing with our study of
certain Kierkegaard's philosophical
fragments actually my favorite book by
him and that's a setting it pretty high
because there's there's a lot of great
works that he authored you know not just
fear and trembling and repetition and
and either-or and sickness unto death
but also his early thesis or rather
dissertation the concept of irony which
is just brilliant
but this is actually I would say in some
ways the most clear and most profound of
his works and here we're actually
getting into the very heart of that
we've been in some ways fencing around
doing some preliminary work talking
about Socrates and and God is as teacher
and different models and what this would
entail talking about things like the
moment versus eternity different modes
of learning about one's own error all
these sorts of things are ways in which
Kierkegaard is carrying out an important
contrast that takes place but is really
here in Chapter three and that in this
appendix on the the offended
consciousness that I hope we can get to
in this lecture that everything is
coming to an absolute crux so you can
look at this building and then after
this it's a lot of making sense out of
things after that after that and this
chapter is called the the absolute
paradox of metaphysical crochet so we
should start out with this notion of
paradox itself that's a term that we we
use quite often but I think sometimes we
don't think about what it means for
something to be a paradox or paradoxical
and it comes from the the Greek words
meaning beyond or against or alongside
of para and DOX up and doke some means
something it's often translated as
opinion but it also means sort of the
ordinary commonly held belief that
people have
that you can find in society that
they're working out and thinking
thinking through so the paradox would be
something that goes against our ordinary
way of thinking about things and not
only our ordinary way of thinking about
things is in our everyday way of
thinking about things but also our
ordinary way of thinking about things as
in a logical way of figuring things out
our logical way of putting things into
perspective so what is a paradox well
one of the simplest paradoxes of all is
called the liars paradox and it's you
know one line I am lying to you right
now and what makes it paradoxical well
if it's true then it has to be false
right because if it's true that I'm
lying to you that I must be making a
false statement to you which means that
well now again it turns out that the
statement actually is true because if I
say I'm lying to you and I'm making a
false statement well then it turns out
to be true but that I can't be lying
can I there's a sort of circular pattern
to this that I actually was fascinated
by when I was an undergraduate I wrote
an entire thesis about this type of
statement and actually found a way to
mathematically and topographically model
it using a MIDI instrument but you know
that's a whole different thing
Kierkegaard is after a whole different
kind of paradox a deeper paradox not
something simply having to do with the
way in which we use logic but you might
say the very logic of existence if
there's a larger logic yes Hegel thought
it was so
he calls the paradox the thinker's he
ashen and he says that one should not
think slightingly of the paradoxical for
this paradox is the source of the
thinkers passion and the thinker without
a paradox is like a lover without
feeling now you're gonna see him
throughout this chapter and really
throughout this entire work and
throughout his work as a whole making
references to love and using love as an
example so there is a paradox of
self-love transforming itself to love in
the larger sense and Kierkegaard is
going to use that as a model a way to
figure out what a paradox would unfold
and so there's the paradox of self love
and then there's the paradox of reason
or oh and you want to know what is that
leading towards what is that
transforming itself into what is going
to happen with it so he says the thinker
without a paradox is like a lover
without feeling it's possible to be a
lover but only in a very trivial sense
not in the full sense of the term to
want to be with somebody to desire them
but not really because you're attracted
to them or not because there's any depth
of your your soul that's stirred by them
at their other approach but just because
you know you want you decided a long
time ago you wanted to be with them and
you're just kind of sticking to that
you're not even sure why that's one way
to it to be like that
he says the highest pitch of every
passion is always to will its own
downfall so this is very interesting
because what we have here is the
deployment of what Hegel called the
dialectic and you're going to see other
people in the history of philosophy also
talking in these terms you know Marx is
taking it on a materialist direction
Kierkegaard doesn't know
employ the word dialectic but he's
really a dialectical thinker so what is
the dialectical movement here that takes
place with a paradox the dialectical
movement is that every passion in
unfolding in developing inevitably wills
its own downfall or you might say
dissolution or perhaps its replacement
by something by something higher
something greater maybe it gives way to
something else you know for instance the
seed is kind of a paradoxical thing
because so long as it remains a seed
down in the dirt and just tries to stick
to to that it's it's not going to unfold
and become what it ought to be the
actual plant that it's supposed to lead
to and there's there's a point where the
seed is coming out of the husk and you
know you can say okay that's a seed
that's what it's supposed to do I
recognize that you know it's a monocot
or a dicot you can look at the number of
leaves and come into all sorts of
conclusions of those sorts but then once
it's actually bursting out of the ground
and the roots are shooting down below
and the seed you know shell itself has
just become sort of a husk that's
disappearing it ceases to be
recognizable as the seed and it's been
replaced by something in this case
greater so the question would it be does
that happen with love does that happen
with thought so he says it's the supreme
passion of the reason for Kierkegaard
this is another very important point if
you're Kierkegaard our our intellectual
life our rationality is not something
that is directly opposed to emotion
passion desire activity it unfolds that
beautiful idea as something that runs
through many other thinkers but but you
see if we're really carried out here in
Kierkegaard reason has a passion
what is the passion well I mean if we go
back to Aristotle
all men by nature desire to know and
what is it that that wants to know in us
is it our desire for food well that
wants to know like what does that taste
like and how can I eat that over there
but that's not wanting to know in the
full sense there is a drive within us
and many philosophers have pointed this
out in the past before Kierkegaard
there's a drive within us a hunger as a
goal actually called it big ear death to
assimilate things to ourselves to wrap
our heads around things to extend our
ourselves and our minds our intellect
our rationality beyond where we
currently are to make sense of the
things that's a desire for us it's a
restless desire and so reason itself you
know you think of Reason as being this
you know coldly logical detached thing
because that's what philosophers often
portray it that way but that's not the
way that real philosophers actually
think about things we are passionate
about thinking things out we get
passionate when we you know can't make
sense out of things when we run into
opposition so I says it's the supreme
passion of the reason to seek a
collision the oldest collision must in
one way or another prove its undoing so
reason itself may be undone by this this
collision the supreme supreme paradox of
all thought is the attempt to discover
something that thought cannot think so
this is an important point and I'm going
to erase this now this way the supreme
passion thought is to find something
that is totally unlike thought that
resists it that thought itself cannot
think so we have something now to fill
it over here the like
unthinkable
and we're gonna come back to that just a
moment so he says this is at that bottom
present in all thinking even in the
thinking of the individual insofar as in
thinking he participates in something
transcending himself so if we're just
thinking about what we've got in front
of us this may not be occurring but as
long as as soon as we start thinking
that you know leads us beyond the
boundaries of ourselves engaging with
reality as soon as we start engaging
with anything that transcends ourselves
anything where there's a little bit of
mystery anything that we don't fully
understand even if we're thinking within
ourselves about you know the human heart
we're participating in something
transcending ourselves but he says habit
dolls are sensibilities and prevents us
from perceiving it so this is something
that Kierkegaard is exposing to us that
he thinks is going on whether we realize
it or not in our thinking and most of
the time we're not actually paying
attention to it so he says I'll skip
ahead a little bit let's think about how
it how it comes about that we have this
this paradoxical thing that takes place
so he says we know what man is and this
wisdom which I shall be the last to hold
and light esteem may become
progressively more richer and more
significant and with it also the truth
but now all the reasons stand still just
as Socrates did for the paradoxical
passion of the reason is aroused and
seeks the collision without rightly
understanding itself it is bent on its
own downfall and now he's going to bring
in love to use as an analog to make
sense of this and I think that's a
brilliant move on his part for for two
reasons one is that we we have an easier
time understanding love on the whole
then we do the workings of our own mind
our rationality
they're both equally primordial part of
who we are to be rational creatures and
to be loving creatures but it's easier
to make sense out of love I think you
know pistil mala ji when it's done right
when it's not just a sort of scholastic
exercise is something very akin to
metaphysics in that it's trying to
figure out what is this act of knowing
what is it for us to be thinking what is
it to try to attain certainty to move
from knowing less or being less certain
to knowing more or being more certain
that's tough to think that's tough to
wrap our heads around but we all have
experience with loving or at least I
hope we all do to some degree so we can
make better work with this I think
you're clear Thanks
so there's that and then there's one
other thing love and knowledge can be
separated apart from each other and in
many people's philosophy love and
knowledge are treated almost as if
they're within two separate domains like
love and the feelings are down here and
knowledge is way up here or maybe you
might switch it around so that love you
know is somehow beyond reason your
rational greater than reason and reason
and the intellect are down here well
that's not that's not the way that
classical Christian philosophy has
treated love and knowledge if you look
at Augustine you look at thinkers going
all the way up until you know some of
the great phenomenologist of the 20th
century love it knowledge cannot be
neatly extricated from each other they
they condition each other so they do for
Kierkegaard as well so here here it
talks about self love self love lies as
the ground of all log or is the ground
in which all love perishes he says man
lives undisturbed a self-centered life
until there awakens within him the
paradox of self
what is the paradox of self-love well
you begin to love to desire another this
is eros although it's not necessarily
tied directly to sexual satisfaction or
something like that but it's a desire
for what you don't have for you so you
want that thing out there because you
actually do love yourself enough to walk
that good thing for you once that starts
kicking in and you begin to love the
other you can do this with you know
chocolate and it's not going to have
this kind of dialectical progression
right chocolate is not going to love you
back chocolate is not going to look into
your eyes and try to figure out who you
are and try to learn about your soul or
awaken desires and you neither will an
animal but a human being can evoke
within us something that begins to pull
us outside of ourselves so we begin with
soft love desiring the other and
desiring the other for our own sake and
then as we get to know the other more we
come to appreciate the other we come to
love the other in a different way and
that requires us at a certain point we
become conscious of this that we cannot
simply indulge your own self-love and
use the other almost like a commodity
that sooner or later there come points
in time where we have to choose between
our own desires and the satisfaction of
those desires and the good of the other
who has other desires who is another
self who is just as real as us and
perhaps as valuable or even more
valuable than than we are so self love
paradoxically ends up leading to
something that goes against self love
this is the dialectical progression
that's why Kierkegaard brings us up he
wants to say that within self love
there's the seeds of its own destruction
so he says the logger is so completely
transformed by the paradox of love he
scarcely recognizes himself that paradox
transforms us the paradox takes place
not just out there in the world but
within us in like manner the paradoxical
passion of the reason well as yet a mere
presentiments retro actively affects man
in his self-knowledge so that he who
thought to know himself
is no longer certain about what he is
what is it then that reason collides
with and notice he's not just doing that
reason in relation to the other person
the world he's talking about trying to
know oneself and human beings are
somewhat of a mystery to themselves the
human heart is not perfectly transparent
Descartes was to some degree wrong in
thinking that our our thought is is
transparent to itself and that we can
sort of you know take our stand on this
luminosity of the coachee toe instead we
try to explore what we are and we find
all sorts of pockets of things that are
tough to make sense of within ourselves
so he says what is this unknown
something with which the reason collides
been inspired by it's paradoxical
passion with the result of unsettling
even man's knowledge of himself
it is instead of just the unlike or the
unthinkable
the unknown it is not a human being and
so far as we know it man is nor is it
any other known thing some some thing of
the universe a book coffee cup a
chalkboard
an environment or something like that so
we're going to call this unknown God
says the God it is nothing more than a
name we assigned to it
the idea of demonstrating that this
unknown something exists could scarcely
suggest itself to the reason and now
he's going to switch things up a bit
he's going to go into a long digression
about arguments or proofs for God's
existence so let's put a little space
and while we're doing that think about
what's going on in this passage why does
he make that transition
well how does reason how does the
intellect or if you think about it in
more personal terms how does the person
who is driven by their their life of the
mind by the desire of reason by the
intellect to get to know things how do
they proceed they don't just sort of
take things on faith or jump into the
first well that presents itself or part
or pick whatever you like they want to
think about it they want to prove it
they want to have reasons given for them
so one of the classical discussions
that's still going on today in
philosophy has to do with arguments or
proofs for God's existence yeah if you
take an intro to philosophy class we're
gonna take a philosophy religion class
you're going to come across you know a
number of them and oftentimes they get
you know put into you know certain basic
categories the ontological arguments
teleological arguments cosmological
arguments Pascal's wager or
romantic arguments moral arguments
there's a lot more I think to to it than
then they actually bring out there's
some of these don't fit quite so well
for instance Anselm's argument is not an
ontological argument in the sense that
Kant made of it but there is a sort of
common drive this idea that you're going
to prove that God exists and then you're
gonna use that to make sense out of
other things so what does Kierkegaard
say he says this wouldn't suggest itself
to the reason that sort of groping in
the dark trying to figure out this
paradox for if the God does not exist it
would of course be impossible to prove
it and if he does exist it would be a
folly to attempt it for at the very
outset in beginning my proof I would
have presupposed it not as doubtful but
as certain and you know if you look at
some of the classical texts in which
there are arguments for God's existence
given that's exactly what he happens
Anselm's pro SLO Jian starts out with
Anselm praying to God then says hey uh
let me think about some things having to
do with you oh I see that you
necessarily exist that even though that
the fool and it you know says in his
heart there is no God if the fool really
thought things through the fool would
see that there has to be God and that
God has to have the easy attributes of
that sort of thing he's saying that in a
prayer to God he's he's never put it
into doubt himself Thomas Aquinas in
providing arguments that are supposed to
maybe convince unbelievers or help
people solidify their their resolution
he's not like abandoning his faith and
putting it into the the balance and then
saying if I can't prove this it's all
gone they're beginning from from that
position already so he says this is what
Kierkegaard says generally speaking it's
a difficult manner to prove that
anything exists what's still worse for
the intrepid souls to undertake the
venture the difficulty is that such that
Fame scarcely awaits to concern
themselves with it the integra
demonstration always turns into
something very different and becomes
an additional development of the
consequences that flow from having
assumed that the object in question
exists
I always reason from existence not for
distance so there's two ways we can go
and Kierkegaard says only the top one
actually works the bottom one is what
seems to be going on in a lot of
arguments for God's existence but it
doesn't really get off the ground so he
says when I move whether I'm moving the
sphere of palpable sensible factor in
the realm of thought I don't for example
prove that a stone exists but that's
some existing thing there was something
that exists is a stone well it's like
the procedure in a court of justice does
not prove that a criminal exists but
that the accused whose existence is
given as a criminal whether we call
existence an excess thorium or the
eternal Prius you know something that's
given before you it's not subject to
demonstration so he says let's take
ample time for consideration and that's
some good advice actually you don't want
to hurry through Kierkegaard any more
than you want to hurry through any great
philosopher you want to linger over
these thoughts until they actually get
their foothold you might say so he says
we don't have any reason for haste as
those who from concern for themselves or
for the God or some other thing must
make haste to get existence demonstrated
and you can think about some people
doing apologetics you know they're
trying to argue for say the existence of
what God is like they often do seem like
they're in a hurry and I think that the
people who do apologetics best are the
ones who are not explicitly engaged in
apologetics but are thinking along with
people are you know not trying to make
everything into one tight systematic way
of viewing things or argument or
anything like that and to provide to
everybody else but are actually
lingering there with other people in
their doubts in their reflections their
speculations that come up putting things
together bit by bit and that takes a
certain kind of trust so he says let's
take Napoleon for example if we were
going to try to prove Napoleon's
existence from Napoleon's deeds so we're
gonna start out with what Napoleon is
like and then argue to the existence of
nicoya
you might think for example of doing
this with Sherlock Holmes you know
everyone knows what Sherlock Holmes is
supposed to be like and he's got that
yeah the pike and he's kind of tall and
very smart along you know the new movies
have kind of a skewed things a little
bit and made him a little bit more
athletic and action hero II than he used
to be but does that mean that Sherlock
Holmes exists because we've come up with
some some attributes no he's a fictional
character
what about Napoleon you know could you
just come up with a bunch of attributes
of Napoleon and then conclude that he
exists it says no you have to assume
that Napoleon exists first and then you
could start worrying about what this guy
is like in a short were like charismatic
all those sorts of things so what about
God he says between the God and his
works there's an absolute relationship
God is not named but a concept is this
perhaps the reason that his essentia
involved it assent exists NTM so essence
involves or implies existence as Spinoza
wanted to say your art is rejecting that
he says the works of God are such that
only the God can perform them
okay so now we're actually looking at
something like a cosmological argument
we see certain things in the world and
we say you know there's there's great
order everything got going order is
teleological of course I know but just
go with me for this there's some sort of
metaphysical processes going on you need
something big to get that going so we're
gonna say well that would be God
well the works from which I would deduce
has existed this character it says
they're not directly and immediately
given the wisdom in nature the goodness
the wisdom and the governance of the
world are these manifest on the face of
things does everybody sees them or are
we not here confronted with the most
terrible temptations to doubt and it is
is it not impossible finally to dispose
of all these doubts well that seems to
be the case I mean now everybody buys by
looking around at the universe that
we're in there wow it must be a guy and
even believers sometimes doubt that sort
of thing particularly when life gets
gets tough when things don't turn out
the way that they're supposed to this is
from such an order of things I'll not
attempt to prove God's existence even if
I begin I never finish why well because
I have to engage in interpretation in
order to make this work an ideal
interpretation he says meaning not a
real you know concrete thing but sort of
you know putting my my not necessarily
blinders been at least filters onto it
perhaps rather than reading into
exegesis the book of the world
no exegesis sorry rather than reading
out of the book of the world things that
are they're actually sort of projecting
it in a so Jesus so he says how does
God's existence emerge from the proof
let's say even even did this sort of
thing how does it actually work in
philosophical
does it follow straight away without any
breach of continuity or do we have an
analogy to these little Cartesian dolls
he talks about as soon as I let the doll
go it stands on his head so we would
call these weebles you know remember the
weebles wobble but they don't fall down
so - with the proof as long as I keep my
hold on the proof you know I'm bending
it down continue to demonstrate the
existence does not come out for no other
reason that I am engaged in trimming it
when I let the proof go poof the
existence is there but this act of
letting go is surely something he says
it's a contribution of mine this is a
big problem the idea is that reason
would see that this leads inevitably
without any contribution on the
reasoning person's part from here to
here but really what's required is some
sort of leap during variant sense some
sort of contribution he says this little
moment brief as it may be it need not be
long it is a leap I'm taking a leap I'm
I'm making the proof actually work now
if that's the case well then reason and
rationality are not exactly what we we
thought they were and if you start
admitting stuff like that doesn't it get
a little dangerous not just with you
know arguments about God but about other
things so I'm gonna skip ahead a little
bit so he says whoever therefore
attempts to demonstrate the existence of
God except in the sense of clarifying
the concept you know starting from
existence and then making sense out of
what it is that exists proves in lieu
thereof something else something which
at times perhaps does not need a proof
and in any case needs none better so
what is he talking about there what is
often called the God of the
Philosopher's you might be able to prove
that there's some sort of unmoved mover
or uncreated cause you know
you know and necessary cause or you know
necessary being or something like that
but is that what we in fact call God
Thomas Aquinas you know concludes this
famous proof by a tall men call this guy
but you know again there's that leap
there isn't there
this Kierkegaard and in a lot of other
people can come along and say that isn't
what I call God what are you talking
about unmoved mover well yeah I guess
that's an attribute of God perhaps but
that isn't what I've been thinking of
when I'm talking like God so that's
that's a real problem so he says if in
the moment of beginning as proof it's
not absolutely undetermined whether the
God exists or not
he doesn't prove it and if it's the son
determined from the beginning he will
never come to begin why not well you
know Hartley from he says fear of
failure since the God perhaps does not
exist partly because he's got nothing to
begin with we have to begin he right
says with existence with something that
we actually have something that's
present or at least present as an
absence you might say so the paradoxical
passion of the reason like he says thus
comes repeatedly into collision with
this unknown which does indeed exist but
is unknown so we took a detour through
these argument through you know
discussion about arguments for God's
existence and we didn't actually come up
with anything positive but something was
taken away a path was closed that we did
need closed off Kierkegaard would say
and so we actually did make some sort of
progress now we're going to try to make
progress in a somewhat different
direction so let's start again reason
reason has a passion and that passion is
to will its own downfall and this is the
unknown
and that unknown is the God about which
we don't we don't really know that much
as it turns out reason comes into
collision with this unknown which does
indeed exist but is unknown and in so
far does not exist reason cannot advance
beyond this point so reason finds itself
you might say it in a trap of its own
making it cannot advance beyond this
point and yet it cannot refrain as
paradoxical miss we're riving at this
limit there's a limit here and from
occupying itself there with so reason
started out over here and it was led by
its own passion to extend itself up to
something that now it's not able to
assimilate it starts realizing its own
limits its own inability to even grasp
its own limits entirely to figure out
what's on the other side and now it says
it can't dismiss its relation to it
simply by asserting the unknown does not
exist and this is one thing that some
philosophers one strategy that the
philosophers have attempted to take
those of the positivistic vent who say
look if it can't be known by my reason
not necessarily by you know pure reason
you know deducing things will often it's
quarter but by a human approach to
experience to thinking to making sense
other things if it can't be thoroughly
made sense out of by those means then it
has no value no existence it's purely
imaginary it's just sort of a phantom of
reason you might say you see some people
like you know for instance David Hume
saying things along those lines even a
manual can't although he has sort of
you know restricted area for things that
can only be thought but it can't be
understood but if they're very small
it's a very small group of things that
fit in there they seem to exemplify that
sort of attitude so does the coarse
minded positivist who says uh everything
that you're talking about is metaphysics
and mysticism well you know the proper
response of that is well yeah we do
metaphysics and mysticism because
there's other stuff besides what has
been thought of in your reasoning or you
know quote the old line from Hamlet you
know there's more on having an earth and
it's thought of in your philosophy
so reason cannot just dismiss its
relation to the unknown because this
involves a relationship itself and
reason is always going to be kind of no
idea can it plagued by that you know the
reason can choose to do that the
reasoning person can't say I'm not going
to think about that stuff
but then you know in the dark hours when
they cease distracting themselves those
sorts of things will come back to haunt
them so then what is this unknown since
the designation of it as the God merely
signifies for it that it's unknown to
say that it is the unknown because it
can't be known and even if it were
capable of being known it could not be
expressed does not satisfy the demands
of passion so you can't get out of it
just by saying well look it's the
unknown I mean unknown is unknown right
that's a tautology and the reason may
say well okay I'll grant you that I
can't fully understand this tell me why
I want to understand that at least I
want to wrap my head around why this is
such a problem for me and why I can't
stop thinking about this so the
like it says it becomes a torment for
passion although it also serves as an as
an excitement and yet the reason can
come no further
so what then is this unknown it is the
limit again limit to which reason
repeatedly comes an end so far
substituting a static form of conception
for the dynamic is the different the
absolutely different what does he mean
by by substituting a static form for a
dynamic well when we're actually
thinking concretely as human beings we
are in process we are dynamic we are
engaged in an activity where things
change over over time we assimilate
things we reject things insofar as we
can represent it to ourselves maybe it's
saying you know put it into a textbook
or or a philosophical system it becomes
static it has to it has to stay in place
status means staying in place among
other things so when we do that we turn
this into the absolutely different
because it is absolutely different
there's no mark by which it could be
distinguished
when qualified is absolutely different
it seems on the verge of disclosure it
seems like by saying that it's the
absolutely different we're actually
getting our head around it and figuring
out what what is this thing and now a
dialectical progression takes place that
Kierkegaard again doesn't call a
dialectical progression and I see sort
of five stages in this so we're going to
go through these now reason cannot
conceive an absolute unlike this reason
is unable to figure out what would it be
for something to be so radically
different
you can't even attribute the word
different to it it cannot negate itself
absolutely but uses itself for that
purpose so reason secretly
is forming a conception here it's using
itself and it thus conceives only such
an unlike 'no swith in itself as it can
conceive by means of itself so the
difference is reflected into reason we
can call this the idea or the conception
of difference which is not the same
thing as the absolutely different reason
cannabic negated self absolutely it uses
itself for the purpose now it cannot
absolutely transcend itself and hence
conceives only such a superiority over
itself as I can conceive by means of
itself
there's a lot of salts in there let's
let's run through what this actually
means this is the second stage so reason
is coming up with this idea advanced
part of reasons own province right and
it's using this idea of difference as a
way to transcend itself it's it's
generating a security or superiority
over itself within itself so reason is
kind of splitting within itself as if
there's a higher reason that grasps this
difference and the fact that it is
different and then a lower reason well
this is very similar to what you know
Hegel and Kant and other German idealist
we're actually talking about Kierkegaard
is going through a kind of similar
process here without bringing anybody up
you have to read between the lines a
little bit so he says unless the unknown
remains a mirror limiting conception
here's where the third important
movement is going to take place the
single idea of difference will be thrown
into a state of confusion and now there
will be a number of different ideas
the difference or of difference of many
differences the unknown is then in a
condition of dispersion and the reason
may choose and pleasure reason gets in
sight well I think I like this one or I
think I like this one I like this one
and the imagination may suggest the
monstrous the ludicrous etc now that
sounds okay well you just sort of you
know pick one of these and and now it's
going to make sense and Kierkegaard
actually ties this in with some ideas of
you know what took place in the
development of religions and even within
like you know heretical movements within
the Christian religion and he says this
isn't going to work though so now we get
to the fourth dialectical movement it's
impossible to hold fast to a difference
of this nature every time it's done
every time that reason picks one of
these it realizes that it's an arbitrary
act deep us down in the heart of piety
lurks the mad Caprice which knows that
it itself has produced the gut reason
ends up saying well I'll pick this
absolutely difference different and
we'll call it the logos and we'll
conceive of it in this way and not in
that way or we'll call it Zeus or we'll
call it this or we'll call it the you
know aroma or pick whatever you like and
deep inside of its heart this reason
does it hurt it realizes yeah you know
I'm kind of manufacturing this myself it
wants to have a relation to this but
it's really doing something within
itself
so it says if no specific determination
a difference can be held fast because
there's no distinguishing mark like and
unlike finally become identified with
each other I mean here he actually talks
about dialectical opposites if you know
if this is arbitrary then this is
arbitrary then this is arbitrary why
pick any of them now we're back to
almost a square one but we're not
actually back to square one
he says the unlike miss Klingon reason
and confounds it so that the reason this
is very important this is the fifth
dialectical movement the reason no
longer knows itself and quite
consistently confuses itself with the
unlike miss as for this last name
supposition the self-irony of the reason
he says I shall not attempt to delineate
it merely by a stroke or two without
raising any question of its being
historical and now he tells something
that's almost like a parable except that
you can recognize it as one of the
central doctrines of Christianity
there exists an individual whose
appearance is precisely like that of
other men and he goes through a bunch of
ways in which this is the case since
this man is also the God how do I know I
cannot have know it for in order to know
it I would have to know the gun fired if
I were just reason trying to figure this
sort of stuff out I could reason by
itself could never deduce the god man
could never realize that that had to be
the case it can only make sense of it
afterwards all right so it says I cannot
know it for in order to know it I would
have to know the God and the nature of
the difference between the God and man
and this I cannot know because reason is
reduced it to likeness with with that
from which it was unlike and then thus
the God becomes the most terrible of
deceivers because the reason has
deceived itself reason has brought the
God as close as possible and yet he is
as far away as ever so we've made three
movements so far we've looked at reason
and the paradox the reason necessarily
because it is also a passion brings
about its own disillusion or its own
limits its own destruction because it's
driven to know what I can't know to
eclipse itself to transcend itself that
was the first movement the second
movement was this digression about
proofs for God's existence and we
realized that as far as Kierkegaard is
concerned you're not going to solve
these problems about figuring out things
by God just by having reason kind of
project things out of itself or looking
at the world and making sense out of
those or just using some idea like you
know the idea of perfection and coming
to to understand it that way the third
movement was this dialectical
progression where reason now realizes
that it's grappling with what is
fundamentally different from itself what
it can't fully grasp what
can't even grasp whether it grasps well
or not and then tries to make sense of
that but only within its own scope
generating ideas within itself and then
finally sort of you know realizing wow I
have spent a lot of time spinning stuff
out of myself and I'm no closer to
understanding the unknown the God that
which I'm not able to think that I was
before so does that mean that we have to
say ah well game is done reason did its
best we should all just be skeptics or
agnostics and just concentrate on what
we do know you know take a positivist or
a pragmatist sort of stance Kierkegaard
says no why he says
reason in attempting to determine the
unknown as the unlike goes astray and
confounds the unlike with the like from
there it would seem to follow the
further consequence
what's the further consequence now we're
in the fourth major movement in this
this chapter if man is to receive in a
true knowledge about the unknown he must
be made to know that it is unlike him
absolutely unlike him reason tried to
understand this unlike mnestheus it made
a complete mess of it it muddled it all
up it didn't achieve anything this
knowledge the reason cannot possibly
obtain of itself this would be a
self-contradiction does that mean that
we have an opera here the way is closed
off well not necessarily what if
the guy give something too recently now
reason can't predict this reason can't
require it reason can't make this happen
but if the gaps it should if the God
should so choose that to give knowledge
to the reasoning human being then what
is reason thing to do with it you know
there's an initial problem even if it
obtained such knowledge it cannot
understand it and then it says quite
unable to possess such knowledge for how
should the reason be able to understand
what it's absolutely different from
itself well again he says here we're
confronted with the paradox merely to
obtain the knowledge that the God is
unlike him man needs the help of the God
call this help or you can call it grace
right how could the reason be expected
to understand this how can reason now
you in return make a counter movement
and understand this here we seem to be
confronted with the paradox merely to
obtain the knowledge that God is unlike
him man needs the help of the God now he
learns that the God is absolutely
different from him from himself but if
the God and man are absolutely different
this could not be accounted for on the
basis of what man derives from the God
for in so far they're akin their own
likeness must be derived by what man
derives from himself or what he has
brought upon his own head what is this
well this is the category of error or
sin or as he's going to explore in the
ad acoustic illusion this appendix
offense taking offensive things what is
it that the the human being actually
lacked in trying to make sense of us
what are what is God actually providing
here
he is providing the human being with an
understanding of what it means to be a
human being not all by itself but in
relation to something greater than
itself that yet at the same time is
jarring with doesn't doesn't mesh with
an understanding of the human creaturely
condition not just the human condition
but the human creaturely condition what
it is to be something less than the
fullness of being itself so he says what
did he lack the consciousness of sin
which he indeed could no more teach to
another than another could teach it to
him but only the God if the God consents
to become a teacher but this was his
purpose as we have imagined it in order
to become man's teacher that God
proposed to make himself like the
individual man so that he might
understand him more fully so this what's
going on here is not just help or grace
what's going on here is something that
we call it a act the act of the
Incarnation God becoming human and yet
remaining God
so our paradox key regret says is
rendered even more appalling or the same
paradox has the double aspect which
proclaims that the absolute paradox
which was the title of this chapter the
absolute paradise negatively by
revealing the absolute on likeness of
sin positively by proposing to do away
with the absolute on likeness and
absolute likeness so let's do a little
bit more erasing now we've got a lot on
the board matter of fact let's just
clear it all out so we can make sense of
where we where we are now we have
human being who is reason also driven by
passion we have the unknown also known
as God who is radically different from
human beings even different insofar as
God is rational it's a fuller different
consumption fresh analogy than human
beings so what does God give them the
human being has sort of you know have
these ineffectual reaching out trying to
make sense out of things but but is this
failed God provides understanding not
just the the nature but the fact set
yeah and what is God providing there
he's actually providing something
negative we tend to think of a sinister
like a positive act but really as soon
as a as a privation it's a going astray
it's a deprivation of something that
ought to be there if you talk about
disorder there you know the components
of something that's disorderly are
existing they are real they they do
exist in a certain configuration but
that lacking order it's only present
there as as a privation and God allows
to us an understanding of this
negativity within ourselves ourselves
part of the reason why we're you know
we're separated from God why we're not
able to adequately make sense of God as
we want to according to Kierkegaard it
was coming because of this is this fact
of sin he's also doing something else
he's restoring to us a kind of lightness
and that's a gift as well God doesn't
have to give that yeah and that's not
what philosophy is about and you know
that's not what the human condition is
about and then you know the person who
said well okay this is what God revealed
to you can say you know you're not
getting it
you'reyou're too wrapped up in your own
view of what what can fit into the
confines of reason the goal is actually
to sort of expand reason to take in
what's actually being provided to it
so he says reason and it's paradoxical
passion precisely desires its own
downfall but this is also what the
paradox desires and they are at bottom
linked in understanding but this
understanding is present only in the
moment of passion so reason wants to
make sense out of what the and this is
over here the paradox is giving to it
and it's only understanding this through
through passion itself and he says
consider the analogy presented by love
self love lies as the ground of love we
see this as metaphor again but the
paradoxical passion of self-love when at
its highest pitch wills precisely its
own downfall this is also what love
desires so that the two are linked in
mutual understanding and the passion the
moment and this passion itself is love
so if we think in terms of the self love
and the you know love itself
self love wills its own downfall which
ends up being in love and love love so
much you might say that it even loves
the self love and reconstitutes that
with you know in relation to it so he
says why should not the lover find this
conceivable but he who in self love
shrinks from the touch of love can
either understand it nor some of the
courage to venture it since it means is
doubtful such as the passion of love
self love is indeed submerged but now
it has taken captive and becomes loves
folia Optima but may again come to life
and this is a lobster temptation so also
with the paradox in relation to the
reason if we want to think of how we're
ending this and getting away from these
very abstract terms God in giving this
knowledge to the human being who
possesses reason to try to make sense of
to try to understand to try to respond
to God does not take away rationality in
the process does not blot it out does
not say okay just shut up and believe do
what I say turn your brain on it's
really the opposite God is trying to
provoke reason to go beyond its own
self-imposed self centered self blinding
limitations that it is placed upon
itself in part through its own condition
of sin and offense that it is taken to
the very gift of the paradox giving
itself God giving itself through
likeness through knowledge through grace
to human beings so this is a very
different conception of reasoning of
rationality that is being hinted at here
not really worked out fully but hinted
at and with Kierkegaard I don't think
you're ever gonna fully see him go as
far in this direction as I would like to
see him go as people like say Gabrielle
Marcel or Maurice Bloom now
dietrich von Hildebrand went when they
dealt with these sorts of topics but you
know this is where he leaves off now
we're going to have to talk about this
acoustic illusion of the offended
consciousness but I'll leave that for
the next video